ولكن بضل عندما تنظر اليه بتحس في نوع من
القدسيه باللي بيشتغلوا حروفيات
هل هذا مرتبط بذاكرتنا التي تتعلق بالنص
خاصه بالنصوص المقدسه اللي هي مشغوله بهذا
بهذا الاطار يعني حتى زخرفيا مشغوله من
الاطار الحرف ممارسه روحيه
والحرف ممارسه ايضا مقدس ارتبطت بفتره
طويله بالنص الديني وبالنص العرفاني وحتى
اللغات ككل اللغه اخذت هذا النوع من
التبجيل يعني العامل على اللغه والمثقف
وليس شخص عادي تخيل مثلا بفتره معينه كان
الخطاط لا يمكن ان يكتب دون ان يتوضا يعني
كانه يتجه الى صلاه
يتجه الى صلاه يعني فهذا الوصال مع الحرف
هو انقطاع عن العالم وتواصل مع الخالق طيب
ماذا عن غير المسلمين الذين
يصنعون خط جميل جدا يعني احب حروفين
رائعين
زبون الى الصلاه صلاه جميله الفكره يعني
فيها طقس صلاه القلب يعني هي هي الجلال
والقدسيه اللي يفرضها الحرف وايضا على
الممارس يعطي سكينه وهدوء عاليه جدا